vent de colère dans le monde musulman et
plus particulièrement dans les pays
rigoriste tels que l'arabie saoudite le
coup être l'iran ou encore le qatar
s'ils ont condamné l'assassinât de
samuel pâtit plusieurs états désapprouve
la position d' emmanuel macron sur la
publication des caricatures du prophète
de l'islam durant la cérémonie d'hommage
à l'enseignant samuel pâtit décapité
pour avoir montré à ses élèves des
dessins de charlie hebdo
emmanuel macron a déclaré ceci nous ne
renoncerons pas aux caricatures au
dessin même si d'autres reculs l arabie
saoudite par exemple avait exprimé sa
solidarité avec le peuple français mais
les annonces de l'elysée pour lutter
contre le séparatisme ont vite suscité
un flot de réprobation officielle comme
officieuse en jordanie pourtant allié de
la france le ministre des affaires
étrangères à ayman safadi qui n'a aucune
sympathie pour les radicaux a lui aussi
condamné la publication des caricatures
et il en est de même pour le chef de la
diplomatie marocaine depuis les appels
au boycott de produits français se
multiplient dans plusieurs pays du
moyen-orient au qatar par exemple des
chaînes de grande distribution ont ainsi
annoncé qu'elle retirait les produits
français des magasins jusqu'à nouvel
ordre
l'université du qatar a par ailleurs
décidé de reporter la semaine culturelle
française à la suite de latin délibéré à
l'islam et à ses symboles aux couettes
même son de cloche les fromages français
ont été retirés des rayons de certains
magasins quelques 430 agences de voyages
chrétiennes ont suspendu les
réservations de vols vers la france et
certains vont même plus loin un
restaurant par exemple poser des photos
d'emmanuel macron sur le sol afin de
permettre aux clients de piétiner le
président français et cela peut avoir
des conséquences économiques pour la
france car ces pays notamment le qatar
l'arabie saoudite et les émirats arabes
unis représentent un marché de plus en
plus important pour les exportations de
l'industrie agroalimentaire française
mais aussi d'armement qui est source de
gros contrats entre la france et ces
pays
la france a donc tout intérêt à garder
de bonnes relations mais à quel prix si
le boycott s'est vite propagé des
manifestations à gaza au maroc en
tunisie
on eu lieu avec des slogans hostiles à
l'exécutif français
toujours sur le même sujet est la
tension est montée d'un cran entre la
turquie et la france
recep tayyip erdogan qui cible le
président français depuis plusieurs
jours a également appelé au boycott de
nos produits et il est allé plus loin
une campagne de lynchage semblable à
celle contre les juifs d'europe avant la
deuxième guerre mondiale est en train
d'être menées contre les musulmans
tout comme en france certains disent
n'achetez pas les marques turc
je m'adresse ici à ma nation surtout ne
prêtez pas attention aux marques
françaises ne les achetez pas être
difficile donc d'imaginer une accalmie
rapide entre les deux pays même si air
doan a condamné l'assassinât contre
samuel pâtit
face à toutes ces accusations le quai
d'orsay a réagi dans un communiqué
ces appels dénaturent les positions
défendues par la france en faveur de la
liberté de conscience de la liberté
d'expression de la liberté de religion
et du refus de tout appel à la haine
la france est donc dans une position
délicate et les enjeux sont grands
le gouvernement doit défendre corps et
âme la laïcité et lutter contre
l'intégrisme tout en en tenant des
relations commerciales importantes avec
ces pays musulmans une équation
difficile que va devoir résoudre paris